by classic programming environments
only works when
numerical in precision
mathematica machine it is still its first
function we bring the possibility of
doing analytical calculation that it is
still a big plus that we do not find
in any classic environment
I discovered toothed mathematics
in the very first versions
in the 89 90s so it was a
real revolution to discover the
first computer algebra tools offered
by mathematica which
actually allowed people to practice
mathematics on the computer
practically as they are  think because
we are able in very few lines
of code to replace things which
in usual environments were
done in tens of lines
of code that we put in place in one or two
mathematical functions to I have a
training in  engineer and then I
did a doctoral thesis
in mechanics and currently I am
a research professor
r lecturer at the
national school of engineers in metz I do
my research in a
mechanical laboratory and I teach
mathematics and therefore I use
mathematics on many occasions,
particularly in teaching but also
in research
and  opportunity to supervise
industrial projects with students so I have
chosen to present two two
rather significant examples
of the interest of mathematica
in teaching the first example
concerns
the resolution by a
classical technique of fourier series of
the equation of vibrating strings
the second example
it has two parts it is the
approximate resolution of partial differential
equations with mathematica we can
really go back to the basis of these
methods which are analytical approximations
there they understand the
mathematical concept they arrive at
implement it very easily in
simple examples our amphitheatres are
systematically equipped with  e my
video projectors and
graphic tablets connected to a computer on
which there is mathematica where is
the month during my exams
I authorize students to come to
exams with their computer equipped with
mathematica why because I
do not see any  interest in going to
penalize them to give them
lines and lines of calculation by hand
for me it no longer has any interest and
so I had the opportunity at the time
to test several software  computer
algebra
and I was
really convinced of the superiority of
Mathematica for a whole host of reasons
for its robustness for the consistency
of the whole
and above all the ease of
programming